put the camera on her we're gonna get my
sister shot I put it it okay that's
enough back to me cuz then she got a
million followers overnight
hey I'm a cannot you know shoe [ __ ]
bridalplasty y'all that's my sister miss
Mandie signing out miss fangy you didn't
just come back [ __ ] you came through
now sashay away
thank you
I might come back don't tell us the
spotlight yes I was fighting all my the
whole season that was the end and you
know I feel like it's good like I'm
proud of myself that it was not easy
specially for the enemy shell will not
take a foot out my ass it's just like
the same thing again yeah honey I said
it Michelle like to put her foot in my
ass baby all right
some rapid fire about the season that's
not what was the quote of the season for
you
duck whoa I was right my mother today
[ __ ] that's my personal favorite people
probably don't like it but I do what was
the worst fashion moment of the season
the worst fashion how do I pick JK who
was the word the worse maybe no maybe
soldiers first outfit but it was not
like it was a thank you yeah all right
where's it strong Adam it was just a
cute thing it's been a rough journey
getting here I have a cyst I'm currently
in boozing a lip-synch moment of the
season for you'll be making out of it
let's make it out alive and not going
home to a lipstick
[Music]
so anytime I was in the bottom it or I
ain't gonna say you know what was the
best lifting no scrub
[Music]
Ramji is that gonna continue after yeah
we're gonna worry dressed talking about
it today we're just talking about really
yeah we're gonna see where it goes and
see what happens
it's a big question what's going on with
you and Brooke well we get some clear
answers did you already ask Brooklyn
wishing day I'm a copy over she's kept
y'all why ain't that [ __ ] I don't skip
um what's going on with me and Brooklyn
you gonna have to find out stay tuned
because we're gonna believe the Kraken
and I love Brooklyn
[Music]